lot of TV shows portray the feminine  girl as weak and pathetic and so I never  wanted to be the feminine girl as a kid  like I was obsessed with wrestling you  know I've got brothers so you know I was  always like that but the girl that wears  pink and she wears glitter she's always  like falling over and and the guys don't  like her and she's really stupid and  she's not cool you know the girl that  celebrated in the movies is the Tomboy  they love her the one that's playing  football she's one of the lag and so  naturally you start to become that and  then as well you've got the likes of  cardi B Nicki Minaj the stallion all  those people are just empowering women  to be disgusting to twerk sleep around  and these are the female leaders that we  have